hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google today I'm going
to show a demo that's a little bit more
about motivating some of the techniques
i've talked about in previous two
heights episodes i'll walk through some
code but it's going to be a pretty
pretty blistering pace because frankly a
lot of the techniques in the code are
ones that we've already talked about in
the show what i wanted to do with this
application is instead motivate some of
the techniques that i've talked about
specifically around cartoon animation so
it's a little bit hard when you click on
a button and you see it fall down to the
bottom of the screen and squish at the
bottom to understand why you would want
to do that in your application and
frankly most applications probably
shouldn't do that maybe it would be a
little disturbing or silly but there are
some applications that really want to be
more engaging to the user and it's worth
understanding a type of application that
might want to use that to be more
playful and engaging in general more
interactive with the user so i wanted to
show how to use some of these techniques
that we've talked about in previous
episodes as well as in the talk at
Google i/o 2013 called
a moving experience to show how you want
to use some of these cartoon animation
techniques and put them all together in
some larger example to give that more
engaging feeling to the user we're going
to be showing things about anticipation
about overshoot about exaggeration and
in general just being a little bit more
fun engaging and playful so let's take a
look at the demo so here we go we get
into the application and we've got this
button that is bouncing it's ready to go
it wants us to engage so even though
we're not interacting with the
application that's not a reason why the
application can't be interacting with us
so it's trying to attract our attention
here and then eventually we'll fall for
it we'll press on the button this is a
technique that we showed in some earlier
episodes about anticipation where when
we click on the button maybe it doesn't
just have to change color maybe you can
actually physically interact with the
user and actually press in or press out
to show that there's a physical
interaction with the button actually
going down
as the user presses on it so we press
the button and then when we let go watch
carefully
it's going to launch out and then just
keep going so it launches out toward the
user and then we get into this other
activity and this is actually a separate
activity again this is a technique I
talked about in a previous episode about
custom activity animations we're not
running a window animation here which
has a standard way of running where
things scale and fade in instead we're
disabling that and we're running a
custom activity animation by
automatically launching the sub activity
with a white background so it's fully
opaque but it's the same opaque
background as the one we came from but
first we basically animate the stuff to
get out of the way and then the sub
activity launches with that same plain
white background and then the contents
in that activity animate they scale in
so we have the sort of continuous motion
from the previous activity of launching
fading and going past the user and then
the new content coming in with this
custom activity animation so now we're
on the first screen here and we have
some things that look vaguely like
buttons down at the bottom and did you
notice that they they popped in
everything here is about being more
interactive and playful and alive in
general so we can click on one of these
we can say okay and and it's very simple
to write it's just asking for your name
not a lot going on here maybe the game
is is intended for kids right so you
want to make it as simple and
streamlined as possible so as hey yep
I'm going to play I'm the returning
player called Pat okay what difficulty
you're going to play I am awesome at
this game I'm going to be mega hard now
notice when I press on the buttons again
it's that same interactive thing I press
on the button the button actually goes
into the screen away from the user and
then comes back out the springs and
overshoots showing that interactive
model of engaging the user through
actually interacting through the
physical presses and releases on the
screen so as I release the button you're
going to say the same thing you did on
the previous screen which is the button
is going to launch out at the user and
then animate into place at the top of
the screen now you notice an other
element on all of these screens is the
text is going to animate out we have
this sort of flow of the application
going from right to left and we do this
with a little bit of anticipation on the
on the text again a technique that we
saw in a previous demo where the text
will actually skew to the right and then
shift to the left this is like
traditional cartoon animations where
someone's going to run but
before they run they're going to rear
back and get ready which really helps
the user understand exactly what's about
to happen not just during the action but
actually before the action we anticipate
the text is going to anticipate the
animation and then it's going to shift
quickly off the screen and then finally
of course you want to ask for the
child's credit card number because
that's where the real money is right so
that's it we can step through it again
you see the button you see the sort of
engaging playful thing you launch into
the sub activity here pressing the
buttons that buttons are interacting the
text is skewing sort of all this playful
stuff let's take a very quick look at
the code there's a lot of code here but
again the techniques are similar to
techniques that we saw in these previous
dev bytes episode so it's not worth
belaboring these too much so we have
tune game this is the main activity
we're listening for touches on the
button and when we get one we're going
to we're going to animate the scale so
the button scales into the screen away
from the user and when they release
we're going to trap that here and we're
going to launch we're going to animate
back to the regular scale thing but then
we're also going to perform the click
operation which is going to go into the
sub activity so that is down here so
when we play we're going to animate
we're going to keep scaling the button
out from where it was so it's going to
scale and it's also going to fade out at
the same time and come out toward the
user and then when it's done we're going
to launch the the sub activity this new
intent we're going to start the activity
we're going to override the pending
transition I don't want window
animations here I'm already doing my
custom activity animation so you get the
window animations out of the way with
overriding pending transitions with zero
and then it launches the sub activity
which is this player set up activity
here player set up activity has various
elements a lot of code in here not worth
going into again same techniques all
over the place in here we have the
button press listener so when you click
on one of these things it's going to
scale in when you release it's going to
scale back out
to where it was and then when the button
is clicked it's going to animate into
place up at the top of the screen now I
didn't simply want to pop that view out
from where it was because the layout
would have been affected by that instead
I'm going to set that invisible ability
there in its previous state and then I'm
going to create a copy of that button
and animate that in a parent container
as I move that in sort of this virtual
curve of scaling out and then scaling
back down into place at the top of the
screen where it's going to live then the
the text skewing animation again we've
seen this in previous demos that happens
in this custom text view subclass I have
here called skew able textview we're
going to animate the skew property of
the text as it skews to the right and
then shifts over to the left and that
happens by simply animating the skew
value invalidating appropriately also
invalidate the parent around the area of
the skew so we actually erase and redraw
the appropriate area and that's the
utility method for doing that and that's
about it there's a lot of code in here
but again we went over the actual
techniques of the the code in detail in
the previous dev bytes episode so be
sure to check those out as well as the
code for this application that should be
available at a link on this YouTube
video Thanks